en la relación x cuadrada más 3 puede
representarse allí como función de x la
forma en cómo está escrita esta relación
es como x
una función que está ahora sí que en
función de y así es como está expresada
ahorita esto es igual a cuadrada más 3
veamos si podemos expresar lo de otra
manera y la forma de hacerlo es despejar
y si x es igual a ye cuadrada más 3
vamos a restar 3 en ambos lados y me va
a quedar x menos 3 es igual a cuadrada y
el siguiente paso hay que poner atención
porque para despejar
james tenemos que sacar la raíz cuadrada
de x menos 3
este resultado puede ser ye igual a raíz
cuadrada de x 3 la raíz positiva o puede
ser
jane igual a menos o la raíz negativa de
x 3 puedo tener cualquiera de estos dos
valores y me va a cumplir con esta
relación tratemos de graficar algunos
puntos de esta relación para que quede
más claro esto voy a dibujar mis ejes
coordinados mi eje x
y les ponemos sus etiquetas x 10 para
que no se confundan y esta gráfica en la
parte positiva de la raíz a partir de x
igual a 3 si x es igual a 3 me lleva a
ser 0 entonces que hay aquí con 3 la
parte positiva de la raíz va a verse más
o menos a algo así ésta es igual a raíz
de x menos 3 y la parte negativa de esto
va a ser más o menos por acá esta es
igual a menos raíz cuadrada de x 3 y
esto pues no es una función si yo elijo
un valor no sé se me ocurre elegir el
valor de 4 si yo pongo este valor de 4
voy a tener una positiva que de hecho es
y también voy a tener otro valor de g en
el eje negativo que va a ser
de hecho menos 1 así que si x es igual a
4 entra a la cajita esta de la relación
y como resultado voy a tener un 1 y un
menos uno así que no podemos expresar
esto como una función matemática de x no
es una función